grande nouvelle c'est fini avec delphine
en fait non c'est pas prêt terminé
battle elle n'a pas cru en mon véganisme
ah oui et nous les vegan on est des gens
très intègre gp à supporter les années
les vega dimanche des décos tête
dimanche avec moi quand même ces textes
ou
de salade et du tout
cela dont les coupes avec un gros
couteau certaines oui non mais
franchement vous avez fait vous avez
quoi ça y est romancière delphine et
puis j'ai un truc qu'elle n'aime pas
c'est le mensonge est toujours été clair
avec elle je vais toujours dit qu'on
était amis amis pour la vie et comme les
produits laitiers d'ailleurs
non mais c'est vrai et vous mais ces
noms vous m'aviez pas mal de passes des
c'est à mon tour de vous enfermer titan
faire face à ces mensonges et aucune
baisse des oui bonsoir hier soir j'ai
assisté à une scène terrible dit on va
essayer de la reconquérir une dernière
fois dans les couloirs a duré très
longtemps il lui a dit franchement
cette semaine elle a pas cédé à
l'argument par arguments elle a démonté
tout ce qu'il disait elle à vue qui vous
étiez vraiment massé qui l ai dit
qu'elle était un menteur un hypocrite
moment là la rupture a été consommée
saisi 1,3 à 22h30 delphine salué un
meeting dit la vérité c'est vrai merci
d'un film d'être de toujours dire la
vérité
l'emprise et j'ai vu j'ai vu j'ai vu sa
part sombre c'est à dire le mensonge et
cornebarrieu
castetnau jacuzzi moi aussi j'ai fait ça
par 100
[Rires]
récemment
qui fait écho chez andré oui mais dans
les couloirs de l'établissement non non
c'est pas vrai nom alors je me destine
t'as vu sa part sombre jean king of the
good défaut mais pas les mentions finans
qui tapent plus confiance ici bas du cou
alors mais il est là mais oui on a
compris maintenant je j'ai vraiment
confiance en vous imaginez les pauvres
il est pas un animateur alors
s'il vous plaît je n'ai pas imaginé
que connaît la vérité moi je m'en fous
non alors je pense qu'on a vraiment une
confiance voilà réciproque et alors
c'est tout voilà un jour un jour
l'amitié verra peut-être quelque chose
vous êtes toujours dans des relations
voilà un petit peu obscur voilà comme
vous guillaume gille j'aime beaucoup
mais c'est vrai que la table finale a
besoin de clarté aujourd'hui la carte et
oui c'est la province et encore floues
au début ça n'existe pas l'amitié homme
femme ah ouais non et bassiste que par
définition ils ont sélectionné par
définition il ya de l'envié pas du tout
matthew dire la vérité ça existe quand
il y en a un qui beaucoup plus moche que
l'autre c'est çà et là
[Applaudissements]
et alors j'irai même plus on peut
trouver très beau un de ses amis moi
j'ai plein de moi j'ai plein de copains
autour de moi mes potes ils sont ils y
sont pas jetés au japon cité un
bouton pas mâché d'autres beaux pas
pareil c'est pas mal moins y'a plein de
potes à moi que j'en ai assez je suis
non c'était beau elle est très beau
c'est les travaux il a du charisme il
est très beau et mais et c'est pour ça
que je traite le vendredi on dit
n'importe quoi
des personnes qu'on ne trouvera bien sûr
avec hbo charismatique intelligent
animée par éric mediapad envie du tout
c'est vrai du tout mais on ne sait quoi
ça c'est parce que je suis casé pas bien
sûr je le teste espace jeunes et du
laurion parler des relations et femmes
oui justement j'ai envie de reparler de
roide surtout parce qu'on est un couple
très amoureux la cabine et carla je vous
dire la vérité et la vérité ce que c'est
qu'est ce que c'est que la vérité quand
un homme et une femme se rencontrent
week-end merci mais témoigne logique
mathématique
énoncée j'allais relève quand un homme
et une femme se rencontrent
dès les premiers instants ils savent
quelle route ils vont prendre ensemble
et delphine et moi quant à démonter dans
mon ax
airbus on s'est dit tous les deux quelle
route prend ton on était en train de
rouler et là on a croisé isabelle et
gilles sur la bande à
[Rires]
quelques kilomètres plus tard on a
croisé benjamin castaldi qui galérait
appelé le payage
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est quand on a vu
hier genton sortir des bons en slip de
l'autoroute
concédée
faut qu'on prenne une décision et cette
décision l'a prise à deux d'affiner mois
et nous avons pris la route la plus
longue et la route la plus longue ouais
c'est la hotte de l'amitié
bien c'est tout tu peux nous mener
jusqu'au bout du monde et delphine et
moi aujourd'hui nous sommes
sami
[Applaudissements]